[Musique]
allez question pour valérie venez vous
avez presque déjà répondu tout à l'heure
c'est quoi dites moi la première fois
que vous avez rencontré cyril oui et ce
qu'il essayait de voudra guillou pas
première fois qu'il est question
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
c'est cyril n'a jamais essayé de me
draguer il a tout de suite été sur le
registre du copain du copain
complètement fou furieux c'est le regard
non non j'ai souvenir de lui dans une
phase dans une radio il y avait des
déchets est pas à ses premiers souvenirs
qui me vient vraiment on se connaissait
à peine y avait des bd
je sais plus fins des apéritifs des
machins et s'est mis à je connaissais
pas ce garçon il a pris le bol comme ça
de trucs il s'est mis à danser avec en
les jetant dans tous les sens ah oui c
était moi c'était ce type il s'est mis à
danser autour de moi en me disant salut
toi ça va et je me suis là je les kane
[Applaudissements]
mais il n'a jamais cherché à hammam
draguer du tout cela dit ouais cela dit
oui j'ai appris en faisant une émission
de radio avec lui mais qu' il avait eu
un petit penchant pour moi alors je sais
pas s'il a dit ça pour rigoler ou pour
plaisanter mais il avait dit d'une façon
un peu sérieuse qui m'a un peu troublé
je ne le cache pas quand on sait que à
cette époque là effectivement que
j'étais à tf1 il avait eu un petit
penchant pour moi mais il ne l'avait
jamais dit et je ne ça ne m'était
absolument pas venu à l'esprit
j'aurais pu dire oui site était
célibataire pardon aurait pu dire oui si
tu avais été cédée matin à l'époque
moi j'étais méchant j'aurais peut-être
oui succombé au charme de série parce
qu'il est et il est très drôle
[Applaudissements]
alors on est venus s'amuser benhaim on
est venu prendre du bon temps la belle
marocaine centre est bon oui je sais il
aurait dit oui j'aurais dit oui ou aqua
basse appareils célibataire si j'aurais
dit oui comme bennama non pas avec ça